hey guys and welcome back to the channel
so uh it looks like my collaboration
video did not get me canceled or get me
fired from work which is huge for me uh
but in addition to that some good
channel news is that I actually have
some kind of cool videos coming up for
ideally my 10 000 subscriber Mark which
I should hit and probably I don't know
one to two years from now so uh when we
get there uh it should be a fun one but
until then let's keep doing some systems
design so let's go ahead and hop into it
alright so the subject of today's video
is going to be performing joins in batch
jobs that's right I said batch jobs get
your mind out of the gutter so basically
the premise of this is that a lot of
times during batch computations we want
to be joining multiple data sets now you
can think of this as a typical SQL join
where we've got two different tables or
basically two different groups of files
and they share some common key probably
the key that you get out of mapping
those files to just a key and a value
pair and we want to be able to join on
that key so for example let's imagine
that I was doing some sort of experiment
to try and at the most popular websites
amongst people with a certain
demographic for example if I had two
data sets right here where I had like a
name to their demographic and also
another data set with kind of the name
and some of the websites that they've
been to you could perform a join that
actually merges on that common key which
is the name in this case so how does
this work in practice because when we're
talking about big data we have to be
very very careful about the way that
we're actually shifting our data over
the network and shifting our data on our
hard drive in order to make sure that
our joins are deeply optimized and that
we don't spend a ton of wasted resources
performing them
so we're going to talk about three
different types of joins and each of
them has some pretty big performance
implications so it's important that you
understand what's actually going on very
well so the first type is going to be
the sort merge joint and this is the
most general of the three that we'll be
talking about today we'll see why in a
little bit so let's imagine that we've
got our two data sets right here as we
can see data set one and data set two
and basically on each of those let's
imagine that we've just got two
different partitions in reality of
course we could have 10 15 20 a million
partitions but we'll imagine there's
just two for now and uh you know two
keys on each partition so the first
thing that we're going to do is we're
going to start out with all of our data
as shown right here this is our first
step and let's imagine this is like post
the mapping phase so now all of our data
has both a key and a value and we want
to be able to join on that key so the
first thing that we're going to do is on
every single node for both data sets
we're going to perform a sort and then
finally
after performing the sort as you can see
here on every single partition we've got
sorted data which looks great we're
going to perform the merge so what the
merge really means in reality is that
we're going to do the shuffle stage of
the mapreduce where we're basically
taking the hash of every single key and
then putting it on some partition so
basically we're just partitioning our
keys up consistently between the two
data sets so imagine that what that
effectively meant was that you know this
node over here has keys A and B and this
node over here has keys C and D so the
reason that it's so helpful to us that
we have all of those keys sorted is it
means that we're effectively merging a
bunch of sorted lists which makes our
join super easy it also means that we
can perform the entirety of our join on
disk so we don't have to worry about any
potential memory constraints on every
single system because all of these are
just a bunch of sorted lists we can go
through each sorted list and basically
run our o of n merge algorithm where we
look at just the first element of each
list and keep a pointer for each so we
don't have a lot of memory overhead here
in fact for something like this we would
probably actually use like a heap where
every single list that we're potentially
merging is in the Heap and then we have
a pointer to the smallest element or
rather the current element of each list
in each of them but again that's kind of
getting a little in detail the point is
we can do this all on disk and that's
really nice for us because the fact
these lists are sorted
so let's talk about sword merge join a
little bit because it's kind of
important to understand why it works and
also maybe sometimes why it's not the
best choice so my first thing is that
basically we can always do this the
reasoning being that we can always
repartition our data and make sure that
the two data sets have basically the
same keys on the same nodes which is
very important we can always also make
sure to sort our data because again
sorting our data allows us to be able to
perform the merge and the actual join
itself using only data on disk we don't
have to have any specific memory kind of
qualifications for our systems in order
to perform this type of thing at the
same time the big issue with assortment
showing is that they can be really
really slow the reasoning being that
first of all we literally have to sort
all of our data and when we have huge
data sets that can take a super long
time keep in mind that sorting is
typically n log n complexity and if we
have a data set with bajillions of rows
bajillion times M log n is really really
big
a nice thing here would be if those data
sets were already indexed especially if
they were already indexed in the same
way we could take out the sort step and
then the fact that we could literally
just go ahead and merge them on disk
would actually be pretty easy in fact it
would even be ideal
okay another thing that is problematic
with the sword merch join is that
basically we have to go ahead and send
at least one of the two data sets over
the network assuming that we need to
re-partition at least one of them right
because we want to make sure that they
are partitioned in the same way and
assuming that uh you know we need to
re-partition at least one of those data
sets to make sure that that's happening
we have to send the entirety of it over
the network and if that's a big data set
again that is going to take forever so
having to kind of deal with that use
case or deal with that situation where
we're sending a whole thing over the
network is really going to slow us down
and when possible we would like to avoid
that especially if one of those data
sets is massive so what could we
actually do however if one of those data
sets was massive but the other was
pretty small well this is where
something known as the broadcast hash
join comes in so as you can see we've
got a small data set and then we've got
a big data set with multiple shards and
in this case we're basically assuming
that we have a data set that is so small
that it can fit entire alien memory so
we're joining that small data set with a
huge data set where we have to have many
many partitions over a shared data file
system like Hadoop or something so what
we can actually do is every single node
that the data in our big cluster lives
on we can actually send the small data
set to it over the network which again
isn't a huge deal because it's pretty
small and we can fit it entirely in
memory which again is not a huge deal
because that's kind of the assumption
that we're making so let's imagine our
small data set is literally just this
right here where we say key B has the
value of 21 and Z has the value of 30
and then again obviously it's the same
data set on Shard 2. so we're keeping
that whole thing in memory and then now
we've got our big data set right over
here and what you should notice which is
actually really really nice about the
broadcast hash join is that we don't
actually have to sort our big data set
we can keep it exactly as is because all
we have to do now is iterate through
every single row of the big data set and
then check to see if it matches in the
hash map so basically we would say oh is
a in the hash map
we'd say nope so there's no join there
is B in the hash map yes it is so
there's a join that's all o of one so
it's super easy so basically all we have
to do now is a linear scan of our data
instead of having to do a sort which
saves us a lot of time and effort and
then we can do the same thing over on
Shard 2 we would say oh Z in the hash
map yes it is is y no it's not
etc etc etc and again
this is huge because we don't need to
sort the big data set and sorting is
obviously worse time complexity than
just scanning through which is again
going to be really really nice for us
that being said again a problem with the
broadcast hash join is it assumes that
you have one of your two joining data
sets that is small enough to fit
completely in memory on all of your
machines in your Hadoop cluster and in
reality this oftentimes isn't the case
but there is a decent amount of the time
where it's possible that you can
actually fit certain partitions of the
data set in memory if we partition it in
a small enough way and this is what is
known as partition hash joins so this is
really really useful if both data sets
are too big to fit in memory but they're
partitioned the same way by key and so
they don't necessarily have to start on
the same node but the gist is that you
send the proper corresponding partitions
of the small data set over to the proper
corresponding partitions of the big data
set and then you can go ahead and do
another hash join where we go through
every single row of the bigger table
linearly and check if it's in this guy
over here
and so again what this allows us to do
is it saves us having to send the big
data set over the network and in
addition to that it also stops us from
having to sort the big data set which is
very very important as you can see we've
got basically Shard one over here
corresponding with Shard one of the big
data set and then the small data set
Shard too
is also on a different node
corresponding with Shard 2 of the big
data set and then again we can do our
linear scan perform our hash join where
we say Z in here no it's not is y in
here no it's not it's X in here yes it
is now we have a join so we can see that
X goes to 57 21. and so hash joins are
pretty simple to do
so what's our conclusion well in an
ideal case scenario you would have the
foresight to know what type of joins
you're going to be doing on your data
and as a result of that you would
actually you know start by actually
partitioning and indexing your data in
the same way on the same key the
reasoning being that if your data is
partitioned and indexed to the same way
and you want to join it all you have to
do is send the smaller data set right
over to the bigger data set and you can
literally just perform that join right
on disk and in fact you wouldn't even
have to do a complete linear scan in
that case because of the fact that the
data is already sorted you could
basically do a binary search and perform
that join even faster
however the point is though that
oftentimes in reality this isn't the
case a lot of people want to you know
kind of make joins up after the fact and
when this comes about we're going to
have to get creative in order to save a
lot of time in our data pipelines this
is legitimately something that I had to
use in my old job at Google and I was
ultimately able to take certain
pipelines that took multiple hours to
run and make them take minutes to run by
choosing a better methodology of joining
so again when we come across a situation
like this where in theory you might
think hey I may actually just have to do
a sort merge join here look for cases
where you can do either a broadcast or a
partitioned hash join because they will
save you significant amounts of time you
won't have to sort your massive data set
you won't have to potentially send it
over the network and that is a huge deal
so anyways guys hope you enjoyed this
video this is a topic that I personally
enjoy talking about and thinking about a
lot and so yeah hope uh it helped you
guys as well have a good one and I will
see you in the next video